howard the other interesting person in
our zoo meetings
is benji as you would suspect everybody
seems to know how to work
everything correctly with the exception
of benji
sometimes benji's on sometimes he's not
sometimes his camera's on sometimes it's
not
is he really that [ __ ] up gary like i
mean i used to think it was like a
schtick or something but
like why is he always the guy with the
problem like why is it always benji who
yeah why is it so hard for you dude i
can't even
see you like why is yours
are you doing this now on purpose no
i mean i mean i'm going let me see you
doing normal let me see you look normal
on zoom
i see what you're doing i can't even see
you
why do you not know how to do it what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
it's fine wait what's wrong with it now
we're laughing at the benji puppet
i don't see the phone wait what's wrong
why is your like why is robin squared
off gary squared off
red squared off why are you not squared
off like why
why because the f because i'm the phone
but like why haven't you figured out how
like everyone else has figured out
we've been doing this for two months now
well i'm being serious now
does this look good the way i am right
now no let me explain
your bars there's a big metal plate
going across
like i know you want to show off your
dog we can't even see the dog because
the metal plate is
yeah great fourth [ __ ] dog
didn't benji tell you he thinks if he
holds his dog it makes him more likeable
lovable and guess what it doesn't huh no
but he did he did tell us that he thinks
that this
makes him look look slimmer but who
cares we know you're fat
what do you mean yeah but i do look
better at certain angles so let me
when you say just set up your phone so
you look like gary and robin to me right
now
yeah but uh when you say to turn on the
mic i have to
do things to the phone so it changes it
for a second
so that's that's what the so when i turn
it
on do you not have a computer i have a
computer
then why don't you use that because
i'm doing something else thank you yeah
all right wait wait
no no that makes sense all right thank
you benji
but this is this is bs because i'm fine
right now yeah
you're great no you're fine we need you
to be fine for us
yeah all right thanks binge thank you
bye hold on let me get chicken
chicken come here no no i don't want
chicken
but you'll like me when i'm holding her
what is chicken that's your dog
yeah yeah the dog is trying to escape
that's his chance
get out now she's on he's on with me
chicken
get out come here chicky come here
oh [ __ ] it she's so cute look at the
benji puppet he's got the same
computer